outside the US the balancing act of
restarting economies while minimizing
the potential health risks is playing
out all over the world there are now
more than 5.2 million cases of corona
virus worldwide with the global death
toll topping 338,000 comes as a number
of infections decrease in Asia while
surging in Latin America Roxana Saberi
has more from the foreign desk in London
Roxana good morning good morning Jeff
we're seeing more signs that the virus
hotspots have moved from here in Europe
to South America the World Health
Organization is now calling that region
the new epicenter of the global pandemic
Brazil is reporting more than 330
thousand cases it now has the highest
number of cases in the world after the
US and Russia in Brazil's biggest city
of San Paulo workers have been digging
fresh graves to keep up with the rising
death toll the virus has also reached
indigenous communities in Brazil's
Amazon region where officials say
clinics are overwhelmed for months
Brazil's president Jair bull cenario has
downplayed the threat of the virus so
did the President of Mexico at first
this week his country reported a record
number of infections and deaths almost
daily still the government is moving to
reopen the economy around the world this
weekend most muslim-majority countries
are calling on their citizens to limit
their movements as nearly 2 billion
people prepared to mark the end of the
fasting month of Ramadan and there is
encouraging news in the country where
the outbreak began around 6 months ago
today China is reporting no new
confirmed cases on the mainland for the
first time Michelle Roxana thanks for
the world wrap